[Music]
foreign everyone we could start with
what is potentially mortgage misery for
millions of homeowners who are due to
remortgage or who aren't on a fixed rate
deal three lenders have already
withdrawn products that follows the
Chancellor's mini budget that was
anything but that's booked the markets
and caused the pound to plunge today the
labor leader zakira starmer will reveal
how he would tackle the current cost of
living crisis with some investors
fearing interest rates could Peak at six
percent next year
UK's luggage largest mortgage lender
Halifax has withdrawn mortgage deals
instead offering Arrangement fees in
return for lower interest rates virgin
money has temporarily withdrawn all
mortgage deals for new customers
and so has Skipton Building Society
the bank of England stopped short of
announcing an interest rate hike
yesterday but some investors fear
interest rates could Peak at six percent
next year the chancellor quasi-quarting
is due to set out a medium-term fiscal
plan explaining his thinking on the 23rd
of November
here in Liverpool at the labor
conference the Kia starmer will today
deliver his big ideas on how to save the
country he's channeling the former labor
prime minister sir Tony Blair saying his
party is the political wing of the
British people the labor conference
though taking place against a backdrop
of striking dot workers bringing back
Echoes of the past
[Music]
[Applause]
the mercy
and always take me there the middle of
the 20th century and Jerry and The
Pacemakers were one of the big names on
the mersey beat scene
they seem to smile and say Liverpool was
famous around the world for its thriving
musical influence
George and Ringo better known as The
Beatles from humble beginnings they went
on to be richer than their wildest
dreams
but as their careers soared the city's
economy was faltering key employers
leaving docks closing and inflation on
the rise
[Music]
through a storm half a century later the
city has enjoyed massive regeneration
bartners with the rest of the country
once again Liverpool faces grave
challenges today
stock workers on strike cost of living
challenges and the third most deprived
region in England and now concerns that
the energy crisis is leaving many
families unable to heat their homes this
winter and it's against this backdrop
that labor has brought its conference to
what was once described as the New York
of the northwest
spot what does secure Starman need to do
in the coming weeks to prove that he has
what it takes to unlock the door to
number 10.
[Music]
well that's a great question and as you
can see where streeting is here with us
the shadow Health secretary talking
about those locks there I mean what does
kistama have to do to unlock their
daughter number 10.
I think turn the anger
and frankly discuss with the
conservatives into a positive appetite
for labor and that's what this week's
conference is all about because the late
party conference is one of those weeks
in the year one actually a rare week in
the year in terms of the coverage we get
where the voters can look through the
window judge whether we've got our house
in order and listen to the offer we're
making to the country and I think last
year in terms of the changes here made
to the labor party people could see he
was getting the house in order I think
what you're seeing this year and you'll
certainly get from kirstalmer's speech
late this afternoon and you've got in in
bucket loads from Rachel Reeves
yesterday in her speeches I hope our
country's next Chancellor first woman
Chancellor uh you know we've gone
further we're ready to get the country
back in order because on so many fronts
things are broken whether it's the
economy our Public Services the sense of
Law and Order in our country and labor
has serious people with a serious plan
to get Britain working again and to give
Britain a fresh start it needs how much
has he Rewritten his speech
uh I I think all of us
are frankly are still recovering from
our Jaws hitting the floor last week
with that budget from quasi-quarting and
the real world consequences we're seeing
overnight the withdrawal of uh mortgage
products tells us about the extent to
which the chancellor our own Chancellor
in this country has frightened the
markets and and and as a result lenders
having to change the offer they're
making to Consumers this is just the tip
of the iceberg if interest rates go up
in the way that some people are
predicting that's going to be huge
additional cost to people with mortgages
and and what was the Chancellor's answer
yesterday don't worry folks in November
I'm going to come out with some new
fiscal rules I.E I've ignored all the
ones I've already got and I'm rewriting
the rules of making it up as I go along
this isn't serious leadership it's a
reckless Gamble and as Rachel Reeve said
yesterday it's not the chance law
there's trust that are going to be
paying the price for this he's gambling
with other people's money and we're
seeing the consequences for that in real
world consequences right now which will
affect family finances in the middle of
a cost of living crime question how much
is he Rewritten a speech
I'm not been looking over his shoulder
I'm sure he's talked to you about it yes
he has and I think the fundamentals
remain the same our analysis of where
the country has gotten wrong it it you
know it's not new we've had 12 years of
this now 12 years of the conservatives
making Reckless short-term economic
decisions which haven't worked making
decisions which are short-term missed in
public services which means they're now
largely broken
and Reckless short-term missed decisions
which mean that a whole range of things
that really matter to people
the leader must have Rewritten his
speech in order to take in what's
happened of course
with the budget yeah of of of course but
you know we're determined to make sure
the next election
we've got a serious plan that is both I
guess radical in its ambition but also
reassuring because I think people need
to know that there are still some
serious grown-up people in Westminster
that there is a serious alternative
government available and we're used to
sort of Left Right divides in in
politics and some of the conventional
um choices that people always have
between conservative policies and labor
policies we've now got the central
dividing line which is also responsible
labor versus irresponsible conservatives
what are we going to do about people who
want to borrow money to for a mortgage
you know that three lenders are already
withdrawn I'm guessing that is just the
tip of the iceberg
what would you say to them
um I'd say the Cavalry is coming with
labor on on two fronts one is
essentially two years away people are
worrying about their mortgage yeah
tomorrow and the next day and the day
yeah and so what are you saying to the
lenders and that's a fair challenge but
also okay that's the one we're answering
at this conference you know why is it
frustrating for me being on your program
as an opposition politician because we
we can oppose we can criticize we can
challenge the government we're not in
the driving seat making decisions we've
had enough of that and I think you've
seen at the labor conference this week a
real change in tone in emphasis in
optimism a seriousness about the life
party and a determinants and the viewers
that are watching this morning lenders
you potentially could be in power in two
years time is what you're saying what
you're hoping these people these lenders
will have to work with you yeah that's
right so what are you saying to them now
so two things one is Rachel roof set out
yesterday we've got a serious economic
plan to provide certainty and stability
for business investors to restore
consumer and business confidence I think
people look to Rachel Reeves not as the
shadow Chancellor but as the chancellor
our country needs I think that's the
first thing that provides the conditions
for a stable housing market secondly
grasping the nettle of Reform we need in
the housing market what's one of the
primary things we need to do address
housing Supply so building more homes
homes to buy homes to rent affordable
homes that would make an enormous
difference what about today and tomorrow
and the next day what are you saying to
the lenders
well I'd say to I'd say to the lenders
I I appreciate the conservatives have
made your job so much harder I
appreciate you need to revise the
products that you're offering consumers
as far as you can you know remember the
fact that just over a decade ago that
the country helped Financial Services
out of the massive black hole that dug
themselves into in so far as you can
with the conditions the conservatives
have given you please do your best to
look after consumers at this time think
about those families that are worried
about their mortgage payments really
want to get on the housing ladder have
been scrimping and saving to get that
first deposit to get on that first rung
of the housing ladder and now can see
that dream of home ownership slipping
away do your best to support those
families but my central message because
I'm not interested in opposition and
what we're saying today I'm interested
in what we want to do after the next
election the Cavalry is coming with
labor we've got serious people with a
serious plan that would make an enormous
difference to families right across the
country and to businesses who are the
backbone of our economy and will be the
Bedrock of economic growth I heard um
the boss described as Tony Blair 2.0 is
that a compliment or an insult to look
at Tony Blair's record of winning
elections and delivering real change in
our country I think and I you know put
it this way
I I've been a long-standing fan of kirst
armor if you told me when he was first
elected leader of the labor party that
he would have taken us from that
crushing defeat in 2019 worst defeat
since 1935 to a position today looking
at some of the opinion polls where we're
sort of you know I I think kind of
double looking as labor politicians
thinking you know look at these polls
look at what it would deliver remarkable
transformation I guess the one thing I
do want to say though to your viewers in
the context of those polls it's two
things one we're not taking any voters
for granted we're going to work hard to
earn people's trust
and two we're not relying on the
conservatives to fail to be in
government we've got a positive serious
alternative to offer the country and at
the next election I don't want people to
vote for labor as the least worst option
I want people to go to The Ballot Box
voting to give change a chance with
labor with the Hope belief and
conviction we can deliver real change
for people across our country what a
problem you're going to inherit though
when it comes to the economy of the
country and that's why Kate you know
often changes the biggest risk and
people are sometimes frightened of
change up straight away but risks are
come to the point about tax let me know
at this point the risk now for our
country isn't change with labor it's
continuity with the conservatives and on
taxes we have made the running against
the conservatives on personal taxation I
don't think National Insurance would be
reversed I don't think the basic rate of
income tax would be being cut without
labor making a real run on the argument
that says conservatives have gone for
the pockets of working people as the
first and last resort
um well you saw yesterday from late from
labor from Rachel Reeves that serious
plan for economic growth which would
inject both long-term growth in the
economy whilst at the same time
delivering the you know against the big
challenge of our time in terms of
climate change you know
there won't be an increase in in base in
operate tax though back to 45 top rate
tax we're bringing back you know what
we're going to do which I'm [ __ ] a hoop
about
um serious Workforce plan for the NHS
the biggest expansion of Staff training
in the history Okay the reason I ask you
about 45 because it's actually only a
batch only costs about 2 million pounds
which is a drop in the bucket compared
to the problems that you'll be inherited
but here's the thing especially when
people say oh top rate of tax you know
what difference would that really make
in terms of public Champions I am now
able as I think the country's next
Health secretary to double the number of
medicine training places at University
to have an additional 10 000 places for
training for nursing and Midwifery uh
places double the number of District
nurses put five thousand more Health
visitors into the Health Service a
serious long-term Workforce plan so that
we can arrest this decline in the NHS
but that's what I'm spending the two
billion pounds on you know Rachel Rachel
and let me tell you on behalf of the
rest of the Shadows it's not easy it's
not easy getting money out of Rachel
Reeves because she wants to make sure
that every penny is well spent she tests
our assumptions and our demands and and
but that two billion pounds do you know
what that would deliver it will deliver
the Bedrock for the for the rebuilding
and renewal of the NHS for the 21st
century it will also help the economy
there are a quarter of a million people
you start to pay off our debts because
I'll tell you why Kate because there are
a quarter of a million million people in
our country who are economically
inactive for no other reason than they
are sick and they are tired of waiting
if we get those people treated faster we
get those people back into the labor
market that's one of the drivers of
growth if we invest in the way that
Rachel outlined yesterday in the new
industries of the future in a plan to
put you know new industry new jobs in
parts of the country that have been
de-industrialized and left behind for
too long that's how you get growth into
the economy you don't get growth in the
economy by letting you know boom time
for bankers and abolishing the cap on
Bankers bonuses you don't get growth in
the economy by making a corporation tax
cut conservative government that's what
they say I'll tell you what we'll look
at the numbers
while we're talking about numbers and
looking at the latest opinion poll labor
17 points in the lead but when it comes
to who would be the better prime
minister the latest poll that we've got
Redfield and Wilton strategies they say
40 say Liz trust 36 Kia stama
and that's why we're not taking people
for granted we know we've got more to do
to turn disaffection with the
conservatives into a positive option for
for labor but it goes back to the point
I made earlier really
if you'd have told me when Kia was first
elected leader of light party that he'd
be able to grip this party and make it
serious and and fit for government in
such a short space of time I wouldn't
have believed that I'm not sure even Kia
would have thought it as well but the
late the last hundred polls labor has
been ahead in almost all of them but
when it comes to the actual leader he's
not he's not they think that Liz truss
who a lot of people think that is
mismanaging the economy is still a
better prime minister than kids talk
directly to those voters who haven't
made their mind up on Kirsten and talk
about that well polls to change and can
be changed so let me talk to those
people who haven't made their mind up
about kirstana the kirst armor I work
with is serious he's got serious
experience outside politics he does his
job seriously I think he'd be a serious
prime minister secondly the care star
Marino is in touch with the concerns of
ordinary people across the country
wasn't born with a silver spoon in his
mouth his family aren't particularly
wealthy in terms of his immediate family
and you know he understands the pressure
that people he understands the pressure
people under book third and in stark
contrast to Liz trust he has got the
answers that our country needs whether
it's rebuilding economic growth
rebuilding our public services and
rebuilding a sense of hope and optimism
about future rebuilding Britain's place
in the world you're right if we win the
next general election labor will inherit
crises on all fronts crises at home
crises abroad crisis in terms of the
economy now some of those things like
the war in Ukraine are beyond the
control of this conservative government
and I wouldn't blame them for that but
there are a whole load of problems that
are made in Downing Street and after 12
years of conservative government asking
this lot to fix those crises they've
created is like asking the arsonist to
put out the fire they started it's not
going to happen quick thought before I
let you go on the Liverpool Dockers are
you going to join them on the picket
line no we're going to do one better
actually we're going to deliver a labor
government that improves The Fortunes of
working people across the country in two
years time but you won't join them on
the picket line that's our job no I want
to be in government I want to be solving
problems I don't want to be out on the
streets protest testing I've had enough
of that I did that when I was involved
in student politics I've done that for
years as a labor party member we are
tired of protesting we are ready to
govern that's how we make a difference
for working people final question should
Jeremy corbyn get the whip back no I
don't think you should thank you very
much thank you very much good to see you
thanks a lot bear with us one second
Sadia standing by outside several estate
agents in South London Maddie is with us
on the floor of the city hello to you
both good morning good morning let's go
to the city first of all
um how's the pound doing this morning
morning K well it was a less Torrid
night for the pound less drama today the
pound stabilized um against the dollar
in overnight trading in Asia it's about
one dollar and eight cents that's up
about 1.2 percent where it closed last
night
um although let's not forget last week
before the mini budget it was trading at
1.14 cents
um the pound also up a smidge against
the Euro at about 1 euro 12 cents
um that doesn't mean it's all over
though so that's obviously still down on
last week and investors still not
convinced by the government's huge tax
cuts and economic plan
um we will see this lower lower trading
volumes overnight we will see what
happens when markets open shortly this
morning but today quasi quateng is
meeting the big Banks today to try and
reassure them that's despite the
statements yesterday released by the
treasury in the Bank of England hoping
to calm those Market fears didn't quite
have the effect they hoped for but it
was described to me quasi-quartering
sort of reassurance drive now as trying
to put to the PIN back in a grenade
after it's been taken out so certainly
we will see what happens when markets
open shortly this morning
okay thank you sadio as I said is at an
estate agents in South London for us
this morning hello to
um Saudia I wonder what the housing
market is going to do given what we're
hearing about lenders already
withdrawing their products
well the markets have been in turmoil
since quasi-quarting announced his plan
for the economy last week and this has
been described as the real world
consequences of that volatility with
people with mortgages or people looking
to get mortgages having fewer options to
choose from as you say three lenders
have withdrawn some of their products so
what are they I'll just go through them
with you virgin money have withdrawn
virgin money mortgage products
temporarily for new customers they say
existing applications will still be
processed and no changes to existing
customers Halifax is withdrawing
Products that come with a fee so that's
where
um borrowers could pay an arrangement
fee in exchange for lower interest rates
and the Skipton Building Society has
withdrawn all of its products it says to
reprice again because of this turmoil
and it says that there are no changes to
existing customers or existing
applications and skipped and version
have both said that they expect to
launch new product rates in the next few
days but this will of course have a
knockoff effects not just on home buyers
and people with mortgages but also
businesses like estate agents like the
one I'm outside today and mortgage
brokers who of course facilitate these
transactions
okay ladies thank you both for the
update to be back to you in the next
hour thank you for now Tamara's here
with us hey good morning good morning uh
what do you make of what we're streeting
how to say well he said the Cavalry are
coming in terms of the message to
mortgage lenders and indeed the public
about the possibility of a labor
government and as we wait for the labor
leader kirst armor to give his big
speech this afternoon to the conference
here in Liverpool setting out his stall
as the next prime minister he could not
in his wildest dreams have predicted
this set of circumstances labor with a
17-point lead in a poll by ugov this
morning biggest lead for 20 years and
it's unprecedented turmoil in the
financial markets which Tories are now
openly saying they are deeply concerned
about whether the government can keep
hold of its reputation for economic
credibility kirst armor will be saying
today that it's labor who are the party
of sound money and it's the
conservatives who have squandered that
reputation I think we're going to hear a
very confident speech from the labor
leader more so than we've heard in
previous years it's interesting that it
was hastily Rewritten yeah he's he has
been talking in the last few weeks about
how the real battle is now on the
economy but given the events of the last
few days I think rewrites were going on
until quite a late stage yesterday this
is Kirsten's opportunity to say if you
vote for change with the labor party
they will get us out of this mess in his
view we had labor insiders yesterday
saying that he relishes the challenge of
the economy battling with Liz truss on
policy not as with Boris Johnson as with
personality and integrity issues this is
his opportunity today and as a senior
labor figure was saying to me last night
it now feels like the next election is
his to lose
seen that happen before though have we
not it's good to see you thanks thanks
so much indeed tomorrow tomorrow with us
of course throughout the morning looking
at the morning's papers for you and many
of them leading with the ongoing Market
turmoil triggered by the Chancellor's
mini budget the eye reports that some
mortgage lenders have stopped offering
new home loans with others expected to
follow suit the telegraph has the same
story on its front page with the
headline spooked lenders ditch new
mortgages in pound chaos
the times leads with the bank of
England's response it says it won't
hesitate to raise interest rates after a
day of turmoil
the guardian claims Liz truss's economic
strategy is unraveling as the Sterling
crisis deepens
out of control is the headline in the
Daily Mirror as the conservative party's
mini budget continues to be under
scrutiny
while the male blames speculators for
the plunging pound
and you can watch the labor leaders
speech in full on his plans for the
economy live from 2PM this afternoon
here on Sky News
still to come this hour though amid
fears President Putin could be preparing
to formally Annex large parts of Ukraine
speaking to a former head of the British
army General Lord dunnett
as the falling Pine puts further
pressure on household budgets I'll talk
to the chief exec of the resolution
Foundation Think Tank which focuses on
improving living standards for those on
low to Middle incomes
and On The Fringe of the conference here
in Liverpool speaking to labor for a
republic about why they want to see the
monarchy replaced with an elected head
of state
before that there's some of today's
other news for you starting with Ukraine
there are fears that President Putin
could be preparing to Annex large ways
of Ukrainian territory with referenda on
joining Russia being held in four
regions set to end today the referenda
which are not recognized under
international law are taking place in
the Russian control parts of luhensk and
kirston and in occupied areas of dinex
and zaparitzia by making these regions
part of Russia President Vladimir Putin
could claim that any attacks on them by
Ukraine are a direct attack on Russia
like International correspondent Alex
Rossi is with us now live from Moscow
this morning hello to Alex we were
chatting about this yesterday weren't we
and then of course we've seen uh these
attacks I think 17 in total now on these
conscription offices uh the president
mobilizing more troops into Ukraine
yeah there's kind of okay a twin
strategy going on with the Kremlin for
Ukraine it's desperate at the moment
it's forces have lost the initiative and
they have lost the momentum in the face
of Ukrainian encounter offensives first
of all there are what they are calling
uh referenda going on they are referenda
in name only the International Community
has described them as a sham they're
being carried out under occupation under
the barrel of a gun but those are due to
finish today what it will mean is that
President Putin could formally Annex
those territories so that they become
part of the Russian motherland it would
mean that those territories would then
fall under the military doctrine of the
entire country including the nuclear
umbrella which would be an escalation
and would be allow him to prosecute this
Invasion under Russian law more
forcefully now the other problem he has
of course is the Manpower issue and this
goes to what we're seeing at these
enlistments centers I think more than 20
actually now have been fire bombs we've
seen pictures circulating on social
media of protesters throwing petrol
bombs at these recruitment centers this
has been habit happening across the vast
expanse of Russia we've also seen
protests as well okay now these have
been very small but they have been
taking place everywhere in the Far East
in the south in places like where I am
in the capital in Moscow in Saint
Petersburg and the fact that they are
happening at all even though that they
are small in a police state is
significant it suggests that this policy
he's called it a partial mobilization
but to everybody else it's Mass
conscription is profoundly unpopular and
those protests could get a lot worse now
the key thing to look out for is
probably what happens obviously with the
results of these referenda or these sham
referenda that I think is a foregone
conclusion all of those votes will be
returned that those areas under
occupation will want to join up with
Russia the next thing to look for is
probably on Friday where President Putin
will address the Parliament and it's
quite possible certainly the UK defense
Ministry thinks he may formally announce
annexation of those areas then and
remember we've seen this movie before in
2014 he did a similar thing in Crimea
Crimea of course now coming under Russia
it's part of the Russian territory as
far as the Kremlin is concerned
and Winter's coming of course Alex isn't
it that certainly changes the Dynamics
of any war on soil in Ukraine
yeah that's right I mean battles have
fought over uh space territory and time
now if that territory becomes uh bogged
down as we know it will do in the next
month in Ukraine it could stall the
fighting and make things much more
difficult now it's why there are two
battles going on in Ukraine which are
important to look for one is in back
mootin the Don bass and the other is in
Lyman the jockeying strategically for
those positions will be extremely
important who ends up holding them at
the moment Ukraine has back moot it's
trying to get Lyman from Russian
occupation if it can do that before
winter comes and the territory becomes
boggy it will be significant because it
will mean it will set itself up for when
the ground Thors to launch an even
bigger counter-offensive so those are
the things to look out for on the
battlefield in the coming weeks
okay for now thanks so much indeed thank
you join now by the former head of the
British army that's General Lord done it
of course hello my Lord thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
I'm guessing you would concur with what
we've just heard there from Alex about
the Dynamics changing uh when winter
comes
uh yes that's absolutely right
um there is a certain amount of uh
understandable for frantic action going
on at the present moment to try and get
into good position before winter changes
the dynamic changes the mobility
factions uh or characteristics of of the
battlefield but I think as you're
covering more generally The Wider issues
are the ones probably of greatest
concern at the present moment
um issues such as a referenda going on
in those four four areas
um and also I think looking at it most
broadly the difficulties that Fusion is
coming under the adverse reaction to his
Mass conscription so there are many
areas to watch not just the battlefield
at the present moment
of course and I wanted to come on to
both of those points um if you'll
indulge me let's start with the
referenda first of all
um four areas that are being impacted by
this illegal under international law but
of course the annexation of Crimea was
also uh illegal how do you see that
referenda and its obvious outcome
panning out
well I think there are two obvious
points to make one is that Putin will
claim that the people in those four
areas have now spoken
um with their own voices and they want
to be part of the Russian Federation he
will say that the West will completely
reject that we know because there's no
independent monitoring of the elections
that they are sham they are false they
are purely employed by him so I don't
think that will actually change anything
on the ground I think the concern is the
extent to which Putin might choose to
back up his rhetoric that in saying that
those four areas have chosen to join the
Russian Federation that they the
Russians will defend those areas with
all means possible and that brings back
the veiled or not surveilled threat of
of the use of nuclear weapons and that
obviously is concerning and always
through we've known there's a bit of
nuclear Shadow over this which puts him
from time to time refers back to trying
to put a threat of fear understand
generally in the West
in my experience if a man says I'm not
bluffing he usually is what did you
think
well if it wasn't true they wouldn't
deny this I know exactly what you mean
Kate I think the thing is that the
Americans and NATO are quite wisely
saying or I suggest you can make your
Bluffs you can make your threats but we
have here the two not seen highly
sophisticated and highly capable
Conventional Weapons and if you use some
kind of nuclear weapon yes of course
we've got the option of responding with
a nuclear weapon but we have got
Conventional Weapons of huge power that
actually could be visited upon you
um if I was in one of the Black Sea
Fleet ships at the present moment I
wouldn't go to bed at night in my bank
very calmly at night it's quite possible
because sing that completes Fleet if we
chose to do so
oh um that's that's that's quite the
thought isn't it talk to me about the um
part mobilization that we're hearing
about we've also heard that conscription
officers uh have been targeted at least
17 of them so far that we know about
according to Russian media so maybe
there are even more uh part mobilization
at the moment
um I'm guessing that could increase
further
well hitherto the war at home in Russia
has been somebody else's problem it's
been the problem of the of the regular
army if you like with those who have
been conscripted in the course of the
last 12 months and the normal course of
events now with his decision to go for
a partial mobilization although actually
it's rather more than that they are
pretty desperately trying to conscript
anybody that they can and the talk of
calling up reservist is pretty false
it's frankly just a an effort to harvest
as many men as they can and put them in
uniform that process has now made it not
somebody else's War it's made it
everyone's War and the Russian people
are not entirely but many many Russian
people are reacting adversely against it
I mean you've only got to look at the
pictures of the cues for people trying
to get into Georgia and not to not to
mention the attacks as you've just
suggested on many recruitment offices
this is deeply unpopular and the
unpopularity and the fact it's affecting
many people is now hitting home to
ordinary Russians so Putin has got an
increasing problem at home of his own
making
um did he have any alternatives actually
probably not because for the casualties
that they've taken killed and and
wounded he was running out of manpower
just as he's probably running out of
virtually everything else to do with his
military he's not going to give up he's
going to double down and this double
Downing is uh
the conscription and the who who bring
up for people to go into his military is
causing him an increasing problem at
home it may well be his uh Julius Caesar
moment
but also um you know I I did say you
know if a man says he's bluffing at not
bluffing he normally is but equally if
he is painted into a corner
we should be anxious about that
uh yes we should
um but there as I suggest there are many
dimensions to this it's not just
pressure he might think he's putting on
us it's real pressure on him and it's
also people in Russia looking at him not
just those who are against the war there
is an even more radical element that
actually is against Putin because I
think he's conducted the war so badly
there was an ultra nationalists who may
well decide the time has come for a
palace coup to get rid of him because he
has done so badly and frankly is an
embarrassment
um of course if that were to happen it
does beg the question if Putin was to go
who would follow and would that person
be any better
disappointingly the answer is probably
not
um it's always good to see you my Lord
thank you so much for taking the time
thanks Kate
looking at other headlines we now are
live here in Liverpool uh four people
have been arrested after fights broke
out between German football fans and
England supporters last night the
Metropolitan Police said around 100 men
approached a pub near Wembley two hours
before kickoff and started to assault
customers although some of the group
were wearing England hats police said
they are believed to be German fans
England Drew their final game before
this Winter's World Cup last night
Gareth southgate's side came from two
nil down to lead Germany but conceded a
late equalizer to draw the game
thrill
hundreds of workers at the UK's largest
container Port will stage another strike
today in a disputes over pay 1900
members of the unite Union at felixstow
are expected to walk out until the 5th
of October the union says the seven
percent pay rise imposed on them is a
real terms cut due to the rate of
inflation
hurricane Ian is on track to hit Cuba
and Florida over the next few days with
officials warning residents to take the
category four storm very seriously
several oil companies including BP and
Chevron have shut off oil production in
the Gulf of Mexico
King Charles's new monogram has been
released consisting of the Monarch's
name and title the cipher appears on
government buildings State documents and
on some post boxes it's also used by
government departments and by the Royal
household for franking mail
experts think that drinking coffee
should be considered part of a healthy
lifestyle researchers suggest drinking
two or three cups a day could be linked
to a longer life the drink was also
associated with a lower risk of
cardiovascular disease
now for the first time the RAF has
admitted that it made mistakes with its
recruitment practices after Sky News
highlighted claims that it had
prioritized hiring ethnic minority and
female candidates over white men to hit
impossible diversity targets at events
and security editor that's Deborah
Haynes of course broke the story and has
more
RAF recruitment has been under Fire for
weeks it started when the head of
recruiting resigned in protest at an
alleged order to prioritize ethnic
minority and female candidates over
white men
there have also been claims the Air
Force inflated diversity figures then
over the weekend a former RAF pilot
published a leaked email on his YouTube
channel
just get this straight if they select
based on Merit that's going to be a
problem for the Royal Air Force because
they have targets they need to achieve
set by the chief verstoff
written by an officer based here at Raf
cramwell the email from April last year
discussed how the Royal Navy was
developing a scoring system to rank
candidates according to Merit
it said the ref could certainly use this
on occasion but the email went on I
still hold the view that moving to a
merit-based sift using scores achieved
from assessments for candidates would be
problematic for the RAF with huge
implications on how we do things to
achieve our targets
finally the RAF for the first time has
admitted there had been mistakes
a spokesperson said well overall
standards did not drop in hindsight we
accept that despite the best of
intentions some mistakes were made
the RAF is now confident that our
approach is correct however we are
investigating some processes and
decisions taken in the past
it would be inappropriate to comment
further while this is ongoing all I
would like is an apology for all the
young white men out there the British
white men who put a lot of effort into
education researching the service they
got themselves to a level and I know
they did because I trained boasted them
in my school to present in front of the
airports and they would never give me
the opportunity primarily only because
of the color of their skin and the sex
they were born
Sky News is K Burley earlier this month
repeatedly asked the head of the RAF
what has happened to those responsible
for the recruitment practices
we will do that without any drop of
operational standards we will be very
clear we will be very clear about how we
how we uh how we approach any attempts
to widen that poor little Talent widen
our diversity and we will continue to to
protect the nation uh we we will secure
our skies and Patrol our seas as the RAF
focuses on its Core Business of Defense
an inquiry has been launched following
the resignation of the head of
recruitment
more details are expected to emerge once
that concludes
debraham Sky News
that was an exclusive story first
revealed by our own Deborah Haynes
obviously we'll be keeping an eye on how
that story develops also keeping an eye
on what's Happening Here at Labor Party
Conference expecting the leader to speak
at two o'clock this afternoon we're
hearing that this speech has been
hastily Rewritten given what's been
happening with the economy over the last
few days and of course last Friday when
we had that mini budget that wasn't a
budget wasn't very many for a lot of
people was it I put all of that to
Labor's Shadow Health secretary earlier
on today he said that the government is
gambling with other people's money with
the economic plan they set out on Friday
and as several mortgage lenders pulled
products amid speculation the bank of
England will raise interest rates where
streeting appealed to them to think of
those trying to get on the housing
ladder
the withdrawal of mortgage products
tells us about the extent to which the
chancellor our own Chancellor in this
country has frightened the markets and
and and as a result lenders having to
change the offer they're making to
Consumers this is just the tip of the
iceberg what about today and tomorrow
and the next day what are you saying to
the lenders
well I'd say to I'd say to the lenders
I I appreciate the conservatives have
made your job so much harder I
appreciate you need to revise the
products that you're offering consumers
as far as you can you know remember the
fact that just over a decade ago that
the country helped Financial Services
out of the massive black hole that dug
themselves into insofar as you can with
the conditions the conservatives have
given you please do your best to look
after consumers at this time think about
those families that are worried about
their mortgage payments really want to
get on the housing ladder have been
scrimping and saving to get that first
deposit to get on that first rung of the
housing ladder and now can see that
dream of home ownership slipping away do
your best to support those families but
my my central message because I'm not
interested in opposition and what we're
saying today I'm interested in what we
want to do after the next election the
Cavalry is coming with labor
there we are and not mincing as well as
this is our set here at Labor Party
Conference but we thought we'd take the
opportunity to have a little wander
around as I said kirstama will be
speaking at two o'clock this afternoon
and we will be chatting um leading up to
that and of course afterwards tomorrow's
here
um so kirstama what's he gonna say he's
giving his big speech this afternoon
it's always going to be it's going to be
entirely focused on the economy labor
insiders saying that he relishes this
fight on policy with Liz truss and will
say that it's now labor who is the party
of sound money and the conservatives
have relinquished their reputation for
economic confidence he's saying they're
the ones who cannot be trusted with the
public finances the charge that's often
thrown at Labor so that will be the Crux
of his speech I understand there will be
a big shiny New Economic Policy in there
that we haven't been told about in
advance but I think the key thing for
today is there's a real error of
confidence at this labor conference that
because of the events of recent days of
course on top of everything that
happened with Boris Johnson they're in
with a real chance they've got a 17
point lead in a yougov poll this morning
we haven't seen those kind of numbers in
a couple of decades and he now needs to
use this moment to set out his stall and
say I can be the next prime minister and
convince people outside this hall
because labor have had full Stones
before where they thought they were on
the brink of power but after losing the
last four elections he now needs to say
he is the person who can take them
forward and he'll be quoting Tony Blair
saying that labor is the political wing
of the British people saying after their
crushing defeat in 2019 the party has
now changed and he thinks that they can
now win back people's trust okay let me
relieve you with that if I mean I just
want to show you around a little bit of
where we are so all of these uh our
stalls that have decided to come along
to labor Party Conference we
particularly I don't know if you were
looking at my Twitter feed yesterday but
this van featured on my Twitter feed we
couldn't find a quiet place to record a
voiceover for our package that you saw
at the top of the show so these lovely
people from Royal Mail allowed us to get
into the van I bet it's locked yesterday
allowed us to get into the van to record
our voice over it's an electric vehicle
it's a 3516 they're hoping to have 5 000
by the end of the year and uh something
like 445
000 fans are on the road hoping to
replace all of those with electric
vehicles uh within the next five years
so talking more to uh obviously they'll
tell you a lot better than I can the
Royal Mail also speaking to the nfu as
well and I think ozdoor yep one of the
unions is here too chatting to them and
also speaking about green energy and
saving the best till last a guide dog
for the blind will be joining us also on
the program a little bit later on so all
of that to come looking forward to that
before that though
um how do you feel about spaceships uh
slamming into asteroids
here's more
these are the last few images taken by a
NASA spacecraft seconds before it's
smashed into a 5 million ton asteroid
you can tell by the celebrations back on
Earth the crash was no accident
the dart mission is the first test of a
potential planetary defense system to
deflect dangerous asteroids from our
home planet
NASA chose their target carefully a
small asteroid orbiting another 7
million miles from Earth
Dart approached the asteroid pair Didi
moss and dimorphos at nearly 15 000
miles an hour it aimed for a head-on
collision with a 160 meter wide
dimorphos cameras on a buddy satellite
called leecher Cube recorded the impact
and The Cloud of debris The Hope is the
crash will slow dimorphoses orbit but it
will take months of observations to
prove it has worked
immediately they'll be looking at how
much debris is ejected from the asteroid
after impact the more stuff we come out
the more we move and the campaign to
understand that and how much we've
really uh you know how much we've moved
it will happen over the next year and
there's actually telescopes all across
the globe that are going to be looking
at uh dinamos and dimorphous and trying
to understand how much we've changed
over the next year if an asteroid the
size of dimorphos were to hit Earth it
could destroy a city it's not the size
that this you know going to end life on
the planet but it's large enough that it
could cause a significant problem
if one that size was ever discovered
coming towards Earth and so being able
to do something about that seems like a
very sensible technology to have no
known asteroid large and 140 meters is
expected to collide with Earth in The
Next Century but only 40 percent of the
smaller asteroids have been found
so if Dart proves to have been a success
more campaigns to study and track space
rocks will be needed to spot danger
early enough to leave enough time to
knock it safely out of the way
Tom Clark Sky News
um moved here a little bit further down
in the hall here just behind where the
cameraman is that is where we'll be
hearing from the leader a little bit
later on and just to make me feel at
home I don't know if we can have a look
at this
we've got We've Got Big Ben and the
Palace of Westminster just behind
looking resplendent on the Google stand
here
but that's not why we're here we're here
to talk to the um
Deputy president of the nfu Tom Bradshaw
hi Tom it's good to see you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
tell us why you're here well it's a
great opportunity to us to make sure the
relationships are strong lobbying on
farming's behalf to make sure that food
production really is front and center
and we're such a critical time with the
food inflation that we're seeing and the
production challenges around the world
because of the Ukraine crisis but I
think it's really important that we have
this dialogue with government and with
the opposition and yeah it's a great
time to be here tell me what sort of
challenges your members are facing we we
all know the cost of living crisis is
facing everybody and Energy's driving
that and energy is such an important
part of food production and so it really
is I mean we know that on-farm
inflationary pressures are over 28 over
the past year and that's massively
increasing the cost of production and
with right from eggs and poultry uh
through to milk production there's many
challenges there and a lot of that is
also driven by the Ukraine crisis which
was responsible for over a third of the
wheat exports globally and that really
is pressurizing the commodity markets
and the wheat markets higher which means
that the feed costs for or your poultry
and your pigs are much much harder than
they have been and really squeezing the
cost of production and making it much
higher and then the margins are
difficult to come by what about exchange
rates I mean we're all talking about the
pound against the dollar at the moment I
know and a lot of us a lot of our um
inputs are imported so the exchange
rate's really important from that
perspective but we also it sets our our
internal market prices so in some
respects in the immediate short term for
the products that we're selling we're
slightly insulated from the exchange
rate but it'll make the cut the country
worse off and there are people have less
spending power and so it will go in a
vicious circle and ultimately people
will be able to afford to buy less so
it's crucial that we do have a strong
exchange rate and that we the the
country is seen as being a desirable
currency because it will have a longer
term impacts for us do you remember a
more challenging time for Farmers no
we've had the covid crisis and we
thought that was challenging and then
where we are now with all this
inflationary pressure and the real
squeeze on the cost of living now our
members have to be able to make a margin
from food production and the real
challenge we face at the moment is that
every we're not careful food production
in this country will contract at a time
when globally it's under such pressure
we need to produce more rather than less
and so we are at you know an absolute
Tipping Point and it is crucial that the
policies are put in place really do work
for farming and food production so that
our members can produce not just today
and tomorrow but into next year and
Beyond as well okay
no because you're the man who'll know
this New Zealand trade deal how damaging
is it for British Farmers immediately
especially with a weed currency it's not
a huge threat overnight but the
challenge is if there is a country
that's producing more and New Zealand
can produce incredibly competitively
they have access to some of the tools
that we don't have and I guess we've
always said it's a death by a Thousand
Cuts rather than one trade deal and the
problem with Australia and New Zealand
is that they said a president we've
always said we believe in Fair Trade not
free trade and we believe our members
can compete with any country around the
world if we if we're on a Level Playing
Field but if we're importing product
that we don't have the ability to
produce here if it's using hormones or
if it's using techniques and
technologies that we don't have access
to as Farmers here then we're fighting
with our hands tied behind our back so
the New Zealand trade deal is one thing
then it's then we've got the Australian
trade deal but we know with this
government there's an incredible free
trade agenda we are optimistic about our
Dairy exports and things like that but
only if we really are on that fair uh
Fair playing field and if we yeah are
competing on 30 terms and at the moment
we don't believe that's going to be the
case can I look at your tractor of
course you can thank you tell me about
it well so this is just a little um Red
Tractor it's about 65 horsepower I mean
you wouldn't believe it but this is
about 40 000 pounds if you were to buy
this machine it's much smaller than most
farmers will be using so and the cost of
these is going up with it with inflation
I guess this is double what it would
have been five years ago
and you go have a look
um yep yep you get it yep
so what would you use this for what I
said I mean this is a sort of tractor
that would be used every day on your
livestock farms for you know scraping
out your your cows and just keeping
things tidy feeding and so yeah I mean
you could do a lot of different jobs
with it and I mean it's one of the more
basic tractors of machines that we have
but absolutely crucial it's like a cheap
yeah I mean there's not a lot of room in
here for a guy my size but are you a
farmer by trade yes I am yeah I found
down in Essex all combinable crops
cereal production and so we've actually
been insulated from a lot of the
challenges because wheat prices and
barley prices have increased but our
fertilizer now is about two and a half
times the cost that it was last year so
our working capital requirements are
double what they were this time last
year okay and this would be about 45 000
pounds yeah over forty thousand I would
have thought yeah well it come in a
different color it can come in many
different colors but I I think we do
have the same track to understand next
week so fantastic it's good to talk to
you thanks so much indeed for joining us
thank you thanks a lot let's just wander
this way should we we're moving
backwards there we go and uh as if by
Magic here's tomorrow let's go this way
tomorrow
so talking about the challenges that
farmers are facing yes absolutely and
questions about the brexit deal of
course are going to be thrown at Labor
during this conference as well
interesting to hear Rachel Reeves the
shallow Chancellor yesterday saying
labor will fix the holes in the
government's brexit deal labor don't
tend to want to talk about brexit very
much but this is going to be a question
how they would handle it over the next
few days as well and while there is
obviously a lot of optimism in the air
here because of the government's woes
labor would say are self-inflicted woes
we've got two years until the next
election a lot of a lot of detail to
work through indeed so
um the Tories do exactly the same next
week lib Dems didn't have a conference
yes they had to cancel theirs because of
course it happened during a period of
national mourning following the death of
her majesty the queen and I think they
will probably try and have an event in
London at some stage but you know
parties do spend a lot of money on their
annual conferences they have tons of
their activists there it was a real blow
for them not to be able to have that
conference but labor and the
conservatives have have gone ahead and
you really do see it was interesting
looking at these stalls I was hearing
from labor people last night that there
are more companies and they've had in a
very long time wanting to be here paying
to be here and also wanting um to have
meetings with senior labor Shadow
ministers they are inundated they say
with companies wanting to meet up with
labor labor people so they're feeling
that all those indications are very good
yeah
um
it's the big day today though isn't it
they just leave a speech earlier than
usual usually get it on the last day
which is the Wednesday but it's today
for secure St armor and look the wind
couldn't be fairer in a way got 17 point
lead in a poll this morning I mean it
really set the conference a light last
night labor people couldn't really
believe it then you've got absolute
turmoil in the finances
he is not in his personal ratings but
the fact that you know all I was hearing
from labor people last night is you
think where they were in 2019 on the
floor worst defeat in 80 years to get to
where they are now of course they have
to hold on to this momentum for another
two years and of course inflation could
come down things could change but they
are hoping it's 1995 all over again and
in two years they'll be in a strong
position but of course you know a lot
can happen in those two years but this
is his chance to set out labor store for
him to say we aren't ready to go into
government and also to say some things
about himself and you know his personal
vision and his personal story because of
course he's only given one leader speech
in person before the one before that was
on Zoom so this is he's still relatively
new to the public okay um tomorrow
thanks very much indeed